la tabla muestra al número de tiendas de
una cadena estadounidense de café del
2000 al 2006 el número de tiendas
registrado es el número al comienzo de
cada año en digamos enero 1 o el primero
de enero
y aquí nos da la información a cada año
que es el tiempo t nos dan el número de
tiendas que había aparece entonces
determina una aproximación razonable
para la razón de cambio instantánea de
tiendas de café por año a principios del
2003 ok entonces tomando el promedio de
dos pendientes de dos secantes cercanas
vamos a hacerlo aquí en este en la
herramienta de dibujo y lo que nos están
pidiendo es aproximar la tasa de cambio
instantánea en 2003 muy bien es una
aproximación razonable a la razón de
ca'n instantánea y lo que hay que tomar
es el promedio de dos pendientes de dos
secantes cercanas muy bien entonces aquí
yo tengo graficado digamos el número de
tiendas en cada año 2000 2001 2002 2003
etcétera y lo que nos dice es fíjate en
2003 vamos a ponerlo
con color azul como lo tenemos fíjate en
2003 muy bien quién sabe cómo sea esta
curva quizás va algo así no lo sabemos
quién sabe cómo vaya
pero el detalle es que no importando
cómo va la curva queremos calcular una
aproximación de la recta tangente en
2003 entonces digamos que la recta
tangente en 2003 que bueno no no la
recta tangente sino la pendiente de esa
recta tangente a lo mejor se ve más o
menos así la recta tangente y queremos
aproximar eso como un promedio de dos
dedos recta secantes cercanas por
ejemplo podemos tomar esta de aquí esta
recta secante y también podemos tomar
esta otra
esta otra ok entonces si hacemos el
promedio de esas dos eso será una muy
buena aproximación más o menos de lo que
es la recta tangente en este punto muy
bien entonces vamos a hacer eso digamos
si llamamos a ese dt el número de
tiendas tiendas
y por supuesto es una función que
depende del tiempo aquí va a estar t y
que puede ser los años
pueden ser los años acá están las
tiendas muy bien entonces vamos a
calcular las pendientes de las rectas y
kansas empecemos digamos con la rosa la
rosa la pendiente está pendiente es el
número de tiendas en 2003 - el número de
tiendas en 2002 verdad esto es nuestro
cambio y esto sería este cambio en que
entre la diferencia de años que es 2003
- 2002 entonces esto es muy sencillo
porque abajo nos queda 11 y arriba que
nos da cuántas tiendas había en 2003
había 4 mil 272 menos el número de
tiendas en 2002 que eran 3.500 1
entonces déjenme déjenme hacer esta esta
resta 4272 menos 3.501 entonces decimos
dos menos uno es 1 707 aquí no es 2
sería 12 verdad esto pasa a ser un 3 y
aquí es un 12 12 menos 5 son 7 y 3 menos
tres son 0 entonces nos quedan 771
tiendas tiendas por año por año eso es
digamos la velocidad promedio de
crecimiento del número de tiendas de
2002 a 2003 ok ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular el número de tiendas o
bueno la pendiente de esta recta secante
roja verdad que es más o menos la
velocidad promedio a la que crecieron el
número de tiendas y es lo mismo verdad
tenemos el número de tiendas pero ahora
en 2004 y le restamos el número de
tiendas en 2003 y dividimos entre la
diferencia de los años que es 2004
- 2013 entonces otra vez en el
denominador es sencillo es un 1 y el
número de tiendas en 2004 fueron 5 mil
239 menos el número de tiendas en 2003
que son 4 mil 272 vamos a hacer esto y
nos queda 5 mil 239 menos 4 mil 272 y
decimos 9 menos dos son 7 y aquí no es
un 3 es un vamos a ponerlo como 13 13 7
son 6 muy bien y ahora tenemos uno menos
dos y eso no funciona hay que quitarle
uno aquí y ponerle como un 11 11 menos
dos son siete y cuatro menos cuatro es
cero entonces tenemos es no expenden
once menos dos son nueve no son siete
son
aquí son 94 menos cuatro son cero ahora
sí entonces esto está velocidad promedio
son 967 tiendas por año
muy bien tiendas por año y ahora nos
dice para calcular una aproximación de
esta recta tangente hay que tomarnos el
promedio entonces vamos a sumarle de una
vez a esto de aquí las que teníamos este
número que obtuvimos hace unos momentos
lo sumamos verdad y luego dividimos
entre dos entonces esencialmente lo que
queremos hacer en un promedio es 967 más
771 entre 2 eso es lo que queremos
calcular entonces si los sumamos aquí
nos da 7 más uno son 8 6 y 7 son 13
tenemos 19 y 1 son 10 y 7 son 17 muy
bien entonces estos mil 738 entre 2 hay
que dividir verdad mil 738 entre 2 entre
2 son dos por 8 son 16 para 17 es una
bajamos este 3 y ahora 2 por 6 son 12
para 3 es una bajamos el 8 y 2 por 9 son
18 y nos queda un residuo de 0 así que
el la bueno una aproximación a la tasa
de cambio instantánea serían 869 tiendas
por año en tiendas por año
por año muy bien ahora vamos a ver si
podemos si la respuesta es correcta 869
869 y es correcto